education for adults i took a course of
justice and she was kind of
disappointed
and
it just seemed very conventional
but um
would you would part of your answer be
well on ipad the independent learner can
there's other ways
to get the ipod will ipad will let me
uh
sidestep um
you know finding them for some
we're focused on language and most of
our learners are adults
uh
the typical distance education offerings
are
very similar to what's done in
traditional classrooms
they have the advantage though that they
end it all up with a
test and a diploma
so therefore people go there because
they end up with a diploma
uh the advantage is not so much the ipad
but
if a person
to me the ideal world would be that
schools cannot
give diplomas
there should be diploma granting testing
organizations quite independent of
schools so if i want to gather all the
information relevant to
whatever
i go out and find it when i think i'm
ready i go to the testing plan i spend a
week there and i get property tested and
if i pass i get my degree but right now
it's because they offer the diploma
therefore you've got to go through their
course however bad the course is the
advantage again
accessing via the ipad for example or by
your computer
the resources that are out there is that
there are universities that put all
their courses on the internet
mit does this uh i think the in
languages the university of texas at
austin or something there's more and
more
universities and undoubtedly schools and
you know for high school math there's
this guy in the united states called cam
khan he's got canned the can academy and
he's got
hundreds of lectures on math and science
and stuff like there's just a tremendous
amount of very good learning content on
the web but very often they don't give
you a diploma
so i think the thing about traditional
business education is people go there
because they're going to get
what you say your approach because to me
you are saying
the way nature works
is best because you you you you learn as
a child
coming into this world
and it's exactly how we
it does yes
so it's a very natural way to look at it
and uh
i had no idea when i came here because i
i thought it was about the ipad
this is that yeah i know i should have
yeah yeah
okay sorry oh i'm just kind of asked
about
my
relating i guess my own experience
trying to learn languages in class every
you know
for a long time it's just a question of
reading and
being tutored but then i'm still
translating in my head everything right
it's just translating translating
translating and it's a big rule
now
are there tricks in your system that
sort of get beyond that or you just
ignore it
you know or do you still sort of start
off by translating okay well again
what i do when i start a language i will
listen
many many times to the same content at
the beginning
and not know what that content is oh no
because i read it oh i read it when you
read it
and i'm starting initially with a
30-second bit of content okay and it's
easy and so all the words in fact what
we do is for our beginner content we
have the parallel same beginner content
in all 11 languages so i can actually go
and look at it in english
and i can also look up each word
and i'll listen to that content 10 times
and then and we'll have those typically
in a series so there's like 26 episodes
of this stuff so the first one i do the
second one then first and second third
second third and i listen over and over
and over again and what that tends to do
is it tends to ingrain certain words and
phrases
sort of on your brain and as you
progress you do that most often as you
progress you start to listen once or
twice
because you're keen now that you can
actually do something with the language
you want to hear more and more and more
and read more and more different things
but i find that that in the initial
period really sort of ingrain certain
phrases so that when you go to speak
the phrase will start to roll up so you
you don't have to piece it together word
for word what is this what is that and
put it together you just let yourself go
and so after a while you develop enough
confidence that you know that whatever
kind of phrase starts to roll out of
your mouth is going to more or less be
okay
but if you think about it too much it's
a bit like
like the old story about the centipede
was asked which leg he puts forward
first and then you can walk it
you know or golf if you if you think too
much about your golf swing you can't hit
the golf ball so you kind of have to let
yourself go and that comes with a
certain amount of confidence but
i find that if i spend the first two
three months like out with russia i went
a year i didn't speak to anybody
so i haven't personally some people want
to talk right away i don't and getting
back to her nature the trials so i'm
quite happy to listen depending on the
language for three six months and then
comes up you want to say something
rather than the traditional approach is
to sit someone down and say okay this is
a pen repeat this is a pen
no i'm not ready to say this is a pair
that maybe in six months i'll say this
is a pen and i'm just happy to date it
and so you let the brain gradually
gradually get used to it and don't put
pressure and i personally believe that
where they put pressure on people